let me guess your helmet it was it was
beautiful Titan was like most planets 20
mouths enough to go around
and when we faced extinction I offered a
solution but rand-new
was passionate fair Richard more like
hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a video
for the Eternals franchise that Marvel
just announced they're gonna be doing
what sounds like a new trilogy of
eternals movies they T that idea up
during infinity war with this Thanos
scene where he talks about the history
of his people so I'll explain their
comic book history in how Marvel will
probably tweak their backstory a little
bit in how they can use this as either a
period film or something in present day
because as the name implies the Eternals
have immortality so there are ways that
they can introduce them in the MCU
without completely breaking their
timeline because if they've been alive
this whole time then where have they
been while this has all been going on so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a new round of
that black panther blu-ray giveaway -
all you have to do to enter that it'd
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video but the big deal with the
Eternals in infinity war is is that as
far as we know the Eternals that we're
living on Titan or extinct but that
doesn't mean that they're all extinct
everywhere because they're still
Eternals living on earth or that lived
on earth in the comics so quick comic
book back story the Eternals were
created by the Celestials long before
the Inhumans ever came around the most
recent example of a celestial in the MCU
is ego the Living Planet now he's not a
celestial in the comics but MCU changing
a couple minor things Celestials are
just godlike beings that have existed
since the beginning of time that have
power on a scale that you've never seen
before Galactus level power so in the
comics there's actually a cosmic entity
called eternity that is sort of the
consciousness of the collective
multiverse but in service of sort of
gardening itself it created the
Celestials to go out garden grow things
run experiments tinker with life within
the multi
at will and just see how things went so
the Celestials would come to a planet
they would populate it then they would
come back
eons later to see what it had grown into
and either call it if it didn't work out
or allowed to continue to flourish so
that's why they call Galactus the hunger
he's a servant of the universe he's sort
of the gardener that goes around and
pulls the weeds out so that other things
can grow that's the real reason why he
consumes planets not because he likes to
kill people but because he needs to weed
the universe so that it can continue to
grow so a little bit of fantasies line
of thinking like you erased half of all
life so that the other half can flourish
but there's eons of history between what
we're seeing happen during infinity war
in the original creation of the Eternals
so because they tea up the idea of them
being largely extinct as of the events
of infinity war that's why I think they
might jump around in the timeline
through the eternal series because they
live so long there's ways that you can
include stuff that's happening in
present-day with some of the current
characters like Captain Marvel but
there's just so much rich history that
it would be weird if they didn't have at
least one of these new eternals movies
set during the distant past when they're
first created the Eternals just live
really long like Loki and Thor Thor is
1,500 years old he's still considered a
pretty young man as of infinity war
right now the Eternals can live even
longer than that
Ikaros is a relatively big character
you've seen him on a lot of comic book
covers he's about twenty thousand years
old just to give you an example
but the Celestials created them for the
express purpose of protecting the earth
their celestial experiment against the
deviance in offshoot race so because
Marvel and a lot of the reporters that
are talking about this or using Game of
Thrones analogies think of it as the
forces of man the realm versus the White
Walkers in the night King the reason why
Thanos looks like he does and not like
another human like the other Eternals
living on Titan is because of a genetic
abnormality that expressed making him
look like the deviance eventually what
happens is a very thor ragnarok
situation where half of the Eternals
want to go out and conquer the galaxy
because they're so powerful the other
half just want to be peaceful so it's
like during Ragnarok where you have Odin
who's this very warlike person goes
around conquering stops at nine realms
as Helles says and then chooses more
peaceful ways then banishes hella so
that's essentially what happened to
the Eternals half of them got banished
because they lost the Civil War the ones
that were banished went to Titan but
then later Chronos the leader of the
Eternals that were still living on earth
experimented with cosmic energy big
backfire happened and they all gained
superpowers including their immortality
so Chronos lost his body but one of his
sons a large fan OSes father went to go
find the Eternals that had been banished
after the Civil War found that they'd
all died in subsequent wars that they
themselves had caused because of their
warlike ways save for one woman who
became Thanos's mother so the two of
them started to repopulate Titan and
then it eventually turned into what
you're seeing today the difference in
the comics is that it wasn't
overpopulation that killed the planet it
was actually Thanos himself that came
back and killed all of his people but
you have to remember that while this is
all going on not all of the Eternals
left earth they had these crazy cosmic
abilities some of them just hid out some
of them made pacts with the other gods
of the earth but largely in the pantheon
of Marvel comic books they're not super
popular characters so that's why you
don't see them running around in
present-day with the Avengers and a
bunch of this other stuff that's been
happening more recently so there's sort
of this weird offshoot Jack Kirby race
of people like the Inhumans also very
weird subsequent experiment from another
alien race that was spun out of
experiments that were done on Eternals
so the Inhumans sort of flow from the
Eternals to but they're not the same
thing so that's why I think what they
might try to do is do some of these
movies set in the past and then because
some of them are so powerful and
long-lived you just have one or two
Eternals pop up in present-day and just
say that they've been hiding out this
whole time avoiding any conflicts with
the Avengers in Thanos but the really
big deal about them bringing this into
the MCU in a big way is that it allows
them to do more Celestials so a lot of
you been asking where are the other
Celestials we have Esau on the searcher
in the guardians of the galaxy movie we
know eagle living planet is one of them
now there are many others that are
potentially out there nowhere is
actually the head of a dead celestial so
like when they're flying into that that
actually used to be a living being but I
think part of the idea is is that in
present day a lot of those beings have
either died off because of big conflicts
where they've gone dormant the deviance
themselves worship one of the Celestials
that they call
dreaming celestial so it sounds like
they will invoke a lot of that big
Marvel old-school Jack Kirby mythology
when they do these movies regardless of
what time period they're set during it's
just they've kind of done the job of
introducing the idea like ego the Living
Planet doesn't know what his origin is
he just knows that he was a floating
brain in space that came into
consciousness like I just came into
being that's all I know
so I wouldn't be surprised if not all
the Celestials look exactly like the
Jack Kirby Celestials but there's no way
they're gonna do it without doing some
Jack Kirby just look at Ragnarok all
these Kirby designs in the background
they're just screaming to do more stuff
like this in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so good news bad news situation
if you're a big fan of the Inhumans I
feel like them ramping up for a giant
Eternals saga means that they're
probably not gonna do the Inhumans any
time soon but that doesn't mean that
they'll never do characters like black
bull I mean you never know anything
could change in the future I think that
Kevin Feige is just sort of
cherry-picking really new ideas that
they haven't tried before in big-time
old-school Celestials is something that
they haven't dealt with before like what
is the history of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we really only visited a very
narrow time frame so far but in present
day there aren't that many characters
that are powerful enough to actually
legit be a threat to the Eternals or the
Celestials Captain Marvel is the first
introduction to that in the characters
that wield Infinity stones like Scarlet
Witch Thor has had a lot of comic-book
crossovers with the Celestials but you
get the idea there aren't that many
single characters by themselves that
could actually face one and survived to
tell the tale so just in general I'm
expecting a very Game of Thrones II
style period piece with some connections
to what's happening in present-day
with the idea that in the future we
might see Eternals interacting with the
current characters right now but they
haven't announced when this first
Eternals movie is gonna come out my
first guess is that it's gonna be some
time after guardians 3 like right now
that's the big space based franchise
they'll probably be a small break and
then they'll do other space based movies
eternal sounds like it's meant to be the
first big one in a new franchise so they
just hired the writer they don't usually
hire a writer if they don't plan on
releasing something relatively soon so
I'm guessing this drops the year after
guardians 3 comes out which would be
2021 but congratulations to the giveaway
winner from
last big infinity war video Tommy hawk
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post new Marvel there'll
be more Deadpool to posting tomorrow so
be sure to go see the movie while you
wait for everything click here for my
non-spoilery Deadpool to review and
click here for that soulstone scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you